if you've ever seen The Wizard of Oz on
TV then it's safe to assume that you
will have seen that they went to Oz to
make their dreams come true but god
that's a trek if only they knew if
they'd only taken time to watch the ads
in between parts of the film then they
would have seen a little shop called
Argos and I'm not quite as pretty as as
one can be found in most towns and
cities with all you could dream of all
under one roof a uk-wide high street
chain of good repute at reputation that
this shop deserves just because it's
home to The Wonderful Wizard of Argos
but you needn't worry that the wizard of
the film was just fiction our hero he
doesn't have that to restrict him he
lives all year round just under the desk
putting onto conveyer belts your every
request me wondering how the wizard
spends his weekends replenishing catalog
supplies and little blue pens it goes
without saying that our boss would miss
him in an otherwise fairly questionable
system it's only thanks the efficiency
and skill of this guy you're convinced
you don't want to see what you buy the
speed alone is enough to make you lose
your head if non-conventional shopping
and take this approach instead but right
now I know you're thinking back to the
story you could he help the lion Tin Man
scarecrow and Dorothy well here's what
he'd give to satisfy their requests and
of a sneaking suspicion that you'll be
impressed
the Scarecrow who's always wanted a
brain he'd give a Nintendo DS like brain
training game the Tim man who's always
longed for a heart when he could wound
him ladies with a piece of modern art
the lion will we know that he wanted
courage and so a replica suit of armor
is the answer to his worries and of
course the wizard knows that there's no
place like home for all those people
who'd rather not roam into town so Argos
online is the obvious answer with
guaranteed next day delivery to please
you even faster so next time you find
yourself in trouble or in bother don't
waste your time and energy asking
another if you want a happy ending then
let our wizard write it but here's an
advance warning it's still you that has
to buy it